hello je suis le styliste pour me
trouver tu rentres dans l'appli
messenger et tu table le styliste dû
cliquer sur démarrer pour que notre
aventure commence je t'attends rejoint
vite sur messenger
[Musique]
non mais tu est sublime
ça y est la pure auchan vient de
démarrer vous avez voulu voir ce que oui
j'ai pas besoin de cela pour nous à des
mortes et ils sont nés vendredi saint
pierre l'avantagé avec ma copine isa
c'est que le vendredi ce happy hour une
connerie dit une autre gratuit derrière
vous la retrouvez sur rtl chaque matin
plus grande journaliste et les deux
riders radio qu'est ce qui vous a fait
vraiment sérieux
en plus aujourd'hui et oui on excuse été
vendus sont deux ans avoue que tout à
l'heure jean michel a dit on le film a
peu de moyens on dormait chez l'habitant
et pour une fois qui donc pas lent à 8
ans
elle a eu un rapport sexuel avec thierry
moreau mais non il voulait dire être
formé chez l'acteur chez habitants c'est
ça il ya et ça gagne